questions about health insurance local
medicare advisors are here for you
at no cost we like the sound of that
here's more information from ecos
medicare solutions
the great thing about um an advisor here
are independent agents for
you know for explaining medicare to our
clients
is that you know we get paid by the
carrier okay you may think that's biased
but we get paid the same no matter what
plan we choose from any carrier so it's
unbiased
for us to push you in any one direction
because our compensation is the same
we're gonna find a plan that best fits
your needs
not just the one plan somebody calls you
about we're gonna go
over all the plans from all the major
carriers
here in clark county or washoe county or
nye county
wherever it may be that's what we're
going to do face-to-face
over the phone or on the webinar however
you feel most comfortable and wherever
you feel most comfortable meeting
we we have a staff of 30
agents willing to help you trained
you know by me trained by medicare
trained by the carriers
we got gotta certify every single year
with 80
continuing education hours like a
typical
doctor a lawyer it's only 20. so a
little bit about me
is i am a gerontologist a gerontologist
is the
social psychosocial part of aging in our
senior population
geriatrician is the medical doctor
gerontologist psychosocial
and i was also a professor
at loyola marymount university and in
california and i served 22 years in the
united states air force so i'm a veteran
and i love my veterans and if you have
questions how
the va or tricare works with the
medicare
you give me a call and i'll walk you
through it so when annual enrollment
period comes around
uh it it we can begin start to talk
about that
and october 1st as federally mandated
october 1st
we can begin selling october 15th and it
must
end december 7. if you don't do anything
during that period
you're in what's called lock-in there
are other enrollment periods out there
but this is the key time that you can
make any changes
during this time and they all will be
effective january 1st
when our clients or someone sees
commercials on tv they're going to see
typically one plan and they're going to
talk about how wonderful
and great they are or or they're going
to tell you
hey if you do this you don't got to pay
your part b or if you do this you
you're going to get dental or you're
going to get money back
okay so what we do is we sit down with
you and we show you all those plans and
we'll show you exactly what those
commercials are talking about
some more efficient commercials and if
you qualify i guarantee we'll get you
get you those qualifications for if it
would be
dental or it would be your part b
getting
refunded to you through some type of
give back program
but whatever it is whatever you see you
call me and we'll sit down and we'll
talk about it and i'll make sure you
you understand exactly what the
commercial is talking about or exactly
what
that carrier was trying to describe in
their program
give eco's medicare solutions a call at
702-277-4753 or just visit
ecosmedicaresolutions.com remember this
is a free service
for our local seniors we'll be right
back